what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg and John here today we are going to
wrap up The Witcher season three part one uh with
episode four and five today putting it all in one
video John how are you Tess I am so ready for this
mid-season final nice thanks nice I say yes refer
to that man ooh ladies and gentlemen uh toss a
coin to that like button if you've been enjoying
the Witcher season three or just to show support
for the cavil and uh secondly thank you to all who
have joined us at our patreon page full-length
and watch the longest single with your own copy
of which are available for super sexy rejects
over there also cover several things exclusively
reaction Heights and watch songs included uh we
did shoot episode four on a separate day so uh
we're gonna look a little different for for that
but we'll be looking like this one once we get to
episode five because we did not prepare in advance
to trick you let's get to it thank you [Music]
oh
and then he says your voice cracks never seen
you sleep past Dawn waking him up himself I
have a mission for you and then you clean
up your mess that is all the proof I need
to know that you were ready can I have a
coffee first Francesca will not be an easy
target are you having doubts fringella what
became of her she's dead and you were here
lucky you we must set our differences aside
to create a stronghold rodania acts in their
own interests the posture yes understands
intimately a lot of people understand that
intimately if we are to unite the continent
no more division no more secrets we can all
be our best selves live our best lives no cap
that little speech is turning this turns around
like a fungus grows on you and you're the toe
my friend so now we have to go to aratuza I
thought you said it wasn't safe because of what
you saw in the castle why don't you want to go
there a bunch of Diva [__] because it's filled
with Tatty women who gossip and get sloppy drunk
and I said some things Deanna for that I regret
she'll forgive you she'll write you many letters
invitations are going out across the continent
we expect responses within the day meeting of
the eratusa origami Club you know for someone who
disdains politics you do excel at it this is what
it takes to keep us all safe then it's worth it
the also already agreed to the conclave you can
drop the growth like now never Elizabeth her
room is empty I told the novices to relocate
to loxia for the conclave there was blood
what if she's hurt well then we need to get
less clumsy novices they don't seem concerned at
all by then geralt is bringing Siri everything
yeah you aren't traumatized At All by what Siri
did I've been tracking all the novices who've gone
missing this year yeah they were three or four
more years they couldn't hack it I know these
feels like something check the eel pool
it's a coincidence what are you thinking they're
being used to pretend to be Siri I think they've
been taken by force book monoliths it holds a key
to traveling between spheres what if the person
who's kidnapping those girls is planning to use
the book to banish them or save them themselves
then one problem solved King curries are slow
riding all the way back to go as well and would
take longer besides the passage has already been
arranged beautiful oh damn where'd they shoot this
why are you not on board yet the ferrymen won't
cross he's convinced there's a monster in the
water ooh yes I doubt it's anything that dangerous
maybe we've been focusing so much on my magic but
what about my hunting skills my ability to protect
myself there's a smile if we kill your monster we
accept that as payment for the passage you've
got yourself a deal and the Astro is just gonna
chill while they do this run up in the Scarborough
the tower on than it came down on the ground they
real powerful what do they
want here they're lucky for you
no survivors not even the hobbits this
guy's right on the money that's best
to leave fortune telling to the
soothsayers like a peaceful day
to me peaceful day you brought these guys
on your ship in order to kill something
an acapella group yes rival bards
to say I will always protect you but
every time you leave a mess behind
she's the one who cleans it up if
you're here to use her and abandon
her again tell me now I'll help you
if I tried she knows me at my core that softly
snort makes me wonder if you believe her for
what it's worth I'm happy to see the person
she's become around you it's good I just needed
to get laid the procession has started and your
portal awaits I brought you your mustache for a
camouflage somebody want definitive answers before
we crash the brotherhood's party even Kingdom
event is proposing an alliance soon all the
northern kingdoms will be fighting at upperhast
dastardly was so close to Unity I suspect
it's an issue skin is Roth and covered in
spikes difficult to penetrate except for
a tender patch on the top of its skull
this fight if we're to lure it into proximity we
can strike from above without any harm or damage
to the ferry or anyone on board or it's just a
shark it's a Meg I was personally requested by
the witch Sabrina gloversik should Myers
both my instruments there's two penises
it's a natural Oddity this man we
are gathered here today to honor
the memory of my beloved Queen Hedwig
they put their head just on the body
I was expecting to say to send a liaison for
your little party I've known it was you I would
if I approved this place you guys suck at the
whisper again you should go outside I came here
go on I'm listening and to assure you that the
incident of the Abbey was misguided I also wanted
to invite Philippa as an honored guest at the
conclave of Mages monarchs need more reliable
protection I insist she attend there we go
Jennifer yeser and dextra and radovid I won't take
no for an answer how rad of it's gonna go this
has got interesting and the whole Kingdom goes
and so depressed me [Music]
I love love monster kill them
song about one and they definitely come swim I'm
gonna swallow you up I just learn everything I
know from songs let's keep our enemies close I
am beloved by all and have no enemies there it is
oh oh he lives
oh good the Oscar's gonna fight yeah
that is an astronaut okay [Music]
got this Siri oh the family that slays together
you're the gears oh
[Music]
I am Siri Queen hear me roar the answer never
easy really you adapted at every turn that
took 45 seconds yes a lot easier than it
was made out to be he left these monster
hunts all season have been incredibly short
because the real monster is political gain
wow Jennifer
that's not the real geralt where's Siri we don't
have much time I thought you was with you
what happened no we're in a Flash Forward
sweet
nope it's an illusion
[Music]
I was attacked an illusion I need to talk to
you no something is going on here something
sinister that's right to say I can't know
you need to be careful who you can trust
I was not a suspicious look on your face
whoa what insane visual effects
Magic movie Magic bringing Siri
why is neither good
it's not what I meant just tell her and do
you know when I was most dangerous suppressed
and alone that will not happen to her not as
long as I'm around nothing's gonna harm you
was real in that castle I found young women
who are a part of some horrific experiment
only one of them survived they've implanted
your memories whoever else is working for
their ultimate plan is to manipulate you it's
like a subplot in Days of Our Lives [Laughter]
we have to protect more of these women
from getting hurt and find the majors
behind this yeah where's that faceless lady
she's not faceless that's why we have to go
to aratuta see when you're honest you
get results leaves to break throughs
[Music]
chug chug chug chug chug what do
you mean you can't get any more
oil for a fortnight every bloody Mage in the
World's Gonna Be there and you know that off
drink why don't I started on Mage wait no
I'm hearing that boats are going missing
up and down the western coast war
is in the air greggle you say boats
you guys need to be observing you're working
a bar I just wanted to let you know that I'm
I'm happy to do the other very important
job excellent you'll be looking after Siri
tonight what I mean it was a fan pen come on
let him have this let's never do that again
you guys are so functional you are you fed
her to the magical Lions then I trusted you
making this all up that's also the role of poetry
funny I wonder how she learned such
complete not a disregard for authority
I forgive you your various foolish words indeed
for your socking and posing trying worthy of a man
I forgive you for being a Wily witch who rarely
listens and even more rarely admits to being wrong
let's never do that again but the whole
rest of the show to proceed like this
oh every time truly is a delight
taking your course yeah I'm sure you
do oh now you count money I'm sorry ahead with me
instead of at the party oh I'm not you don't
have to prove what you're going to be in the
future let's be here now I think you're pretty
all right right now well that's the nicest thing
you've ever said to me is orange like a coin
yeah it's like two cents they're just like us
First Watch I have time to go to the party now
I have time to sneak out so that you
have time to sneak out sing us a song
Yes gear if you go be paradise alive with
your true love under Royal one in life
the Raiders are here the rendezviers get rid
of uh the redanians Redondo Beach dwellers yes
message red your future husband
oh careful Bud Serenade serenade
no dude yeah leave the door open
I tried to knock it uh it didn't go well I think
she wants me out of his way fill up her wishes
me to draw you out get information what do
you want yeah well I've slipped away from my
security detail you're in no danger I promise
that force field that blew you back it uh last
Del Dawn I haven't tried I'm scared yes just
saying that makes you Brave I think you know you
don't just see people you see the best in them
I'm with this but I'm also afraid it's a trap
keep your words on eyes they say keep on playing
nice but I have no desire we're just gonna make
out you learn my song am I playing [__] I did
have anything to you oh yeah buddy yeah buddy yeah
about damn time I can't take you inside I'm
sorry all right you could take him inside here
is what they're thinking
oh this is good it's a good thing he's doing
this just who I wanted to see I mean I asked
you to join his search for cirilla of sintra what
is it to you she is the one who is prophesied
he's using you what a friend Jilla seems
to be a theme among your allies could
hear why should I trust you you are smart
because it's the only choice you've got
check for 20 million dollars this is
our first mission as I lies together
for the White Flame a white flame Flame
that guy's such a [__] her her hubby yeah
he's always right behind her so if I don't
agree with anything that I see happening and
no one listens to me I have no power here
's your death your demise that Siri foresaw
dust on her well the chances your book
does too a locator spell could show us
[Music]
holy [__] oh [__] why was backing Orient
is here who uses Illusions hates me and has
a history of experimenting on
young women it's Strega bore
first without solid proof will only throw the
Mages and the northern kingdoms into further
suspicion and had no guard the continent in
the process yes but I want to kill him he's
a trade to the Brotherhood they'll do flowers
to him than even you could let this unfold at
the conclave no one will get to her with the
spell I put on the cabin but if I think it's
Strega bore and they think it's struggabore
then it can't be Strega bore It's gotta be
like tessiah or something we do this together
are you sure about this not to the slightest
well I look in gooseberries now that I can
tolerate you sure about this how are you
damn dude look at these two Henry Cavill
looks good they both look amazing [Music]
The Maccabees Triumph tonight I heard they put
an aphrodisiac in the wine they used to my voice
or maybe it's just wine did you see what Sabrina
was wearing by the way she's older than me yeah
don't compare yourself what is
happening right now I don't know
I feel like we're in a fantasy or
something certainly seems that way
nope there's some good old-fashioned or
romance we just skipped the whole thing
they built to I guess unless it's a
Flash Forward I don't know [Music]
racist dancing is it I don't know is
this apt well now we're both races
because they're always just been staring
it's all for us get used to it they'll
be watching us all night I know you should
know the territory before we step in let's
give them a show we have Sabrina Glover Sig
and Marty Sodom they're passionate lesbians
we have Margarita laurenti current
headmistress and the kiramets and over
by the punches the Plastics who's grown
on me despite my best efforts of hell
are you expecting me to remember all those names
thank God you asked I thought you went to oxenford
that's just for us
don't even think about it she's safe
and knocks here until dawn when the
ball ends and the true concave begins
a lot of people in this room are seeing
the exact same thing Jennifer we need this
ball to go off without a hitch so please
there is to stop eating like an underfed the
Google that was inspired by Henry Cavill trying
to get as much from the catering service on
his last season he's floating up his Witcher
packs with pastries and chips hmm Carol
this is Kerry school friend of mine yeah
speak your food out
you look hungry would you like a taste what what
do you think Witcher do not glamor my man I think
Yan looks particularly lovely this evening oh
he's loyal yeah why did you bring your pet along
if not for us to uh do this why don't
you go and get a drink it's a great
idea pass around the geralt I
hate when women hit on me yep
just the absolute worst just across the continent
but here in Arizona one would be wise to abandon
neutrality I forget you're talking to a commoner
give us the girl before it's too late no excuse me
that's why we love them to say I mentioned
they were together as young majors
first love never goes away does it you worried
best of luck tomorrow at the conclave would
ya what are you playing out vilga forts
Stones it's not optional oh
hell yeah it's not optional
oh it's you are you enjoying everything good she's
the one you need uh don't let her leave your side
I started as a contortionist you know we can
found a new support tomorrow the diseases that
run through this place yeah seriously I'm here
to help I found trying to predict the accident
uh something bad about to happen how is
Siri she's safe [Music] oh Kiss Me Chris
don't worry as long as geralt and Yen become
homecoming king and queen they'll be fine oh yeah
or something kind of hot about how
Henry cavill's behave yeah this is
a good secret now man you're with me I know
we got a job tonight but I could think out
it was you you'll be trying to win Yen back
all evening do you deny it would I deny it
she knows I'm the better man oh yeah then
prove it is this really happening [Music]
this is really happening I can't
tell what's real in this episode
kick his ass girl kick his ass [Music]
I promised you and I wouldn't
make a mess this evening
so I won't too late man oh [__]
whoa I felt very real although it out
oh it's whatever that trance is
in there yeah these magic wisps
amongst majors of the North [Music] they
did it to Sarah and I are optimistic about
the future of this continent based on
what we've seen here tonight and we have
the hell is happening are they gonna assassinate
her or something I don't know anyone's plotting
tonight I could tell from the moment we entered
is that percussion sound nearest serving fog then
oh rather than murder in a steamed members we wait
seek out proof tonight is this this is a different
repeating what happened until then we have to play
nicely if you know who's going to have any kind of
a future here Voldemort I won't be leaving until
I know she's safe here I hear you trust me it's
like the same but different very power what
a surprise got Jenny mice tonight [Laughter]
by the way Marty soda Grand put an aphrodisiac in
that wine hours ago not to mention the
caviar on that plate it's an illusion
cheap ass Mages more like it I suffered quite
the greeting from Sabrina Glover Sig earlier
suffered yep such a painful experience
since you've been tracking the Mage so
diligently you must mean Ranch do you think
his master's here tonight good attempt good
that implies you know trust in what you see
give you an at least a couple of hours to piss
everyone off trust in what you see speak
of the devil and she will appear Philippa
headdress made of Satan's Wings bridania
is your only hope of keeping the lion cubs
safe speaking of simpler times to extreme
remember you're talking to a commoner what
is the purpose of this Choice I'm
not sure I'm saving the continent
rooting out the deadly creatures of redness Hall
not unlike you but you're one of them I am nothing
I care I want to see just how different we are
pulling all this I feel like he's just as likely
as anybody but it could be to say of orchestrating
and all she's at the center of everything as an
artifact the book of monoliths ancient Elven text
that gives a hold of the ability to travel through
time and space Tris and I trace the book here
there's some time traveling happening right now
trackable has it you can get him for
everything he's done someone needs to
get to his office undetected and get the book
before he uses it he's already using it or we
are this is cool I have session Nostalgia
for the first 20 minutes of this episode
I never thought we'd come back
here stunts it's not optional
that percussion sound it could
be like hypnosis or something
[Music]
this was a terrible idea how is Siri
she's safe what someone could take away
what makes her special powers are innate what
if she could have a chance for a normal life
I don't know what Siri would consider
normal that's a good point we need to
immobilize how create a distraction so
you can slip away oh that's why he fought
with this trip okay so we're just filling in
blanks the signal will be truce it's also our
safe word geralt I wanted to apologize
Jenna and I had some important matters
that's what he said you'll be trying
to win Yen back all evening do you
deny it why the [__] would I
deny it prove it unbelievable
yes this is kind of cool it is I guess
I guess I was a little confusing we
restarted well yeah I was like huh I
felt like something timey why me or
hypnotic was going on but maybe it's
just creative displacement of events
oh gods
oh damn it punch me
I was wondering how history
was able to land a punch on
him and why girl would do this in the first place
oh my God our time she didn't hear the
truce line [Music] I'll take that half breed
ugh seems like a real dinghole your guy never
changes and yet I think there's leaders forgive
and forgive well masses not mine you've been hard
at work haven't you corrupting portals kidnapping
novices this guy is awful strikable has been
keeping a list of woven students the ones who
went missing this month he's been conducting
experiments practicing mind control what
but they're Elven so does it matter yeah you
know they're not really you know like people
and we believe his ultimate
aim is set on Surah loves
you have proof of this we do that's right they're
in the safe unless he did something with it
this is the book of monolith the Pokemon ancient
Elven Tom it is the book of monoliths these are
serious allegations I propose Dragonborn is
held until the conclave concludes and we can
have a full trial I can come innocent till
proven guilty wait string of War has been
caught though and he's like owning up to some
of this he was pinned against our own in a time
of unity he's Dragon Ball I kind of stand
by you today maybe it is that guy all right
keeping make sure it doesn't fall into
the wrong hands again under my bed to have
should we missing this
I'm just gonna place a bet on all of them
that's how you win at a horse race to peace
and we have Jennifer work to thank you
yes rather and a nearly perfect evening
I love you oh
it's the first time you've ever
said that to anyone they can't be
cheers good answer did we actually put it off it's
hard to say I'll get flavor on my head how would
you mean literally tonight it's like she wanted
to be on her side tell me everything I care for a
stroll alone no no start from when you guys enter
the party yeah start from when you left yes here
she'd follow her lover anywhere even blindly
towards deaths if he asked it off her
I wondered if you knew the truth what happened
between to Sayo and I oh we only grew close to
her as the years went by until the days
leading up to the First Northern wall
she refused and we won at what cost they held
the wire thread until you tapped into Fire magic
thanks Ian I saw your fault
afraid Sayer and you stick to this plan neither
of you will be any better off than poor Lydia
in love with the poison that killed
fast food thank you for coming tonight I love
it means everything so that means everything
to us as well uh-oh why doesn't that he speak she
was wounded and now she can no longer speak aloud
only communicate telepathically a woman with
a funny voice something Terence said yeah see
you just think so much clearer when you do
it I think her earrings are made of the same
thing what were you doing up there I went up
there after I nearly married it's trackable
he calmed the waves proving magic
need not be evil or destructive
they conformed what would henceforth be known as
the Brotherhood that day my favorite piece here
outcasts I was waiting to deliver this
monologue to you I'd wager we have more in
common than you realize I doubt the parallels
between us are completely parallel [Laughter]
the stronger the Brotherhood will be have you
ever been attracted by the art of sorcery geralt
what is happening join outside in the battle
to come the child will not remain safe for long
your passivity will be no weapon with which
to save her God everyone's campaigning today
let's find neutrality outrage is everywhere
how it subjects me to offers of packs and
agreements and lectures of a necessity of
making a choice and joining the right side
so now I shall respond to events and I'll
adapt to the world as it changes okay to come
forwards encourages conclave to ensure peace
your guys's abilities to recap stories is amazing
ly found in the mines in West Virginia
that's where I found those girls locked in their
Castle the first landing it's that corrupt portal
took me when I was attacked it's Vogue for its
favorite painting he came to say that bracelet
oh my God he's behind it did one of us guess
that last time one of us named him along with a
few others yes yeah it was an episode four Joker
damn it vilga Ford's I like you man I'm trying
to locate okay if she's in danger I need to know
you don't have time I'm not leaving her make sure
oh has the battle begun was can't
even make it to the conclave
damn dick should have chosen a side would you
damn you're gonna leave us like that
now I have to watch the second half of
this part of the Season show whatever see
we set it set it in the review said it wasn't
to say uh one of us said it I don't want care
to find it our patrons know who said it yeah well
probably you is not playing on this YouTube video
yeah I mean it will probably might have happened
is you might have been like maybe it's that one
guy and I was like oh vilgaforts and then we
were both pretty convinced at one point that
it was vilga forts because they kept saying it's
straggabore again I was like ass too much emphasis
on the gas too easy straight or you guessed
it and I'm remembering that and I believed
you regas and I am now taking credit for it it's
one of the two it feels plausible that either of
us could have guessed it there was a determined
answer that it was him it just seemed likely yeah
it seemed likely he's in a fortunate position
to be that guy but I don't care enough to fight
for who's right here I'll go back and look um
this is my favorite one of the season so far
yeah this was fun this is really enjoyable
I love how there was no action No Monsters
and it was really engaging the entire time
and it was paced well it felt very lived in
and uh it was a game of psychology and chess
uh throughout that I thought was excellent
just watching people knock each other off
the table building to the climatic reveal
that the guy to Saya is banging is the baddie
um messed up yeah damn well uh no that was really
good though uh they played with time and for an
episode that kind of Harkens back to the party
episode of episode four which was the reveal that
we were in a different timeline remember that and
we were like what this is not confusing anymore
but they revealed that we were in a different
timeline than for this episode to be revealing uh
to be messing with time and that and then have you
even going I don't know if anything we're watching
is real yeah it was really confusing at first
yeah it definitely got me in that zone of like
oh what kind of Mind Trick illusion is going on
and then it's not really that no this is just the
perspective episode it was Vantage Point yeah and
I think it nicely whipped up just yeah that sorted
sense of paranoid uh you know converging campaigns
and perspectives and all sorts of stuff like yeah
it nicely like throws you off your guard into the
haze of the evening and it kind of plays up how
treacherous I would imagine it has to be to like
you know pull off what are essentially political
Maneuvers but also at a party where everyone's
like hopped up on aphrodisiac wine and stuff
funny because episode four to a lot of
people is like one of the best episodes
so much so that it's like that's episode four
I I remember I I still recall that experience
like yeah this is the episode that made me
fall in love with the show was episode four
and it seems like that's where their strength
is at when you put all the characters you watch
them interact and because everyone's got their
own unique voice unique dialogue and their own
selective motivations and you're watching everyone
with their own intentions putting it forward and
out in the open and then in secret as well and
trying to form alliances there's a lot of fun
to be had there so I this is It's a political
war game and I I really like this one a lot and
you know Henry Cavill was great here he was
so disinterested in the party itself but there
are times where like the misleads really worked
here the missive good misleads yeah and he was
um really sweet too can't wait to see Liam
Hemsworth's replacing I know that's what I think
so they can finally reach the full potential of
the show I know when he said I love you Jennifer
I was like oh I can't wait for them I wish this
moment had been given them I wish the three of
them the first time we're gonna have to hear it
is gonna be Heavies from Henry Cavill you know
you're not gonna get our first I love you with the
Hemsworth I hate Liam Hemsworth as a human being
everyone I hate him I blame him I write him hate
mail for all this it's his fault yeah he wrote
the show wrote them and said you know I think
I'd be a better one and they're like you know
what you're right you know we've been looking for
excuse to kick out old Henry that's what happened
I don't know hey Liam I'll I'll give him a chance
I'll give him a chance I will I think everyone's
gonna give him a chance for morbid curiosity at
least for one episode Henry Cavill just seems so
Irreplaceable he just slips into this so well
yeah he is he he just it seems like he really
knows you know his take of the character and just
feels right at home in this world I don't know
like you can really just feel like Henry cavill's
love of witchering through this stuff even when
he's not having to do as much like witchery stuff
and I like I'd be curious to know how people feel
about this because this leaned in some ways into
like a romance novel quality that I I loved it
I love that I loved it certainly I liked having
this weird wraparound of like them in bed after
the night's over and you know kind of having their
I just wanted to be with you all night you know so
in love with her he's so it's got Temptation
flying left and right and he doesn't give a
[__] he's just like no we're gross get off me
her that's what I want I want Yen her oh like I
gave up internet pornography so I'm not tempted by
you which is yes you temptresses you you sucky why
sure well and especially because like I guess the
aphrodisiac I I guess he had the wine eventually
it's just like it still seems to wanna have all
these amazing orgasms that are being offered my
way this is insanity I'm sure that's every
conversation that happens in an era twos and
party it's just different people promising
different orgasms and eventually you choose
one and you know see how your luck turns out it
made uh it made geralt very unrelatable that's
what Henry Cavill said I'm leaving the show he's
yeah man I'm a commoner I wanted yeah yeah where's
the common man's orgy man would be like yes in
fact I will take all of you let's go back to my
room appreciate the offer I'm not staying at this
party so you can do your own conclave I'm having
my own in my room it is a strange mid-season
finale because it doesn't end in a way of like
oh [__] gotta watch the next one can't wait
or what it doesn't come out for like [Music]
no it doesn't have that at all it's like if it
feels like they were like let's just stop it
here and make everyone wait yeah yeah yeah I mean
I can only stop I can only understand it in the
in the prediction that the rest of the Epic what
is it three left I think so it's like three uh
so it must be like a huge battle sequence or you
know a couple episodes like heavily dealing with
some kind of physical con it sounds like shit's
popping off right now so I would guess that maybe
this was all this sort of political build up to
yeah now the new Sort of hope so Big Bang finale
because uh because yeah if you look at
what stranger things did that made sense
you know they have this massive reveal it
was like oh damn and then they had like
two episodes that are equated to like a full
season of television and and then here it's
yeah I don't know it just doesn't have that impact
oh my God I gotta jog my memory again three weeks
the first part of the episode when I still thought
it was some kind of weird Mind Trick illusion I
was imagining like oh this is a cool way like
yeah this would make perfect sense to end the
season off on because I'm sure at the very end
the truth will be revealed and we'll be like oh
[__] there's no traps they're trapped somewhere
yeah yeah or some reveal like that and then yeah
the way the episode goes like once I got used to
what was happening and how the perspectives were
working I quite enjoyed it you get to the stuff
with Strega board and you're like okay cool this
bad guy I guess is actually just gonna be taken
taken down or held accountable for his misdeeds
and then you get like the turnaround of like
realizing vilgaforts but that's is done in such
a like casual Way Forward yeah it's like with with
Strega bore it's okay that it's straightforward
at first because you're like well even in the
moment I don't know it's like At first you're
like oh well this okay well we suspected him and
uh and and everyone was right and we took him
down and we're just going back to the party and
so like the thing with vilgaforcement it didn't
feel like a victory yeah yeah and it's like it
has that dual quality of like yeah we all knew
this dude was a bad guy from like the very first
season and then also we come back here and like
yeah it's good that he's being taken down that's
clearly something that should have happened but
also it just doesn't feel like this massive like
I'm a little surprised but at the same time yeah
then you're just like oh well then he cannot be
the source of like all this big bad trouble and
strife so yeah and then it goes forth and answers
that and then and then like I get how you leave it
off just like oh man like we thought we were gonna
have this conclave and now there's unrest but
generally speaking just the experience of watching
it yeah it's just sort of like oh this is very
straightforward transition into a pretty mellow
button like it's it portends you know Carnage and
whatever else and excitement to come but as like
an actual resting place it feels like we coasted
to a gradual stop here instead of like you know
going out with a bang or yeah some kind of moment
where you're like [__] I I have to find out yeah
more it's like well I think I know it's a you know
I I expect a battle now this is gonna be some
kind of battle um and is Siri okay I guess she
is uh Siri's fine yeah skiers getting laid Yeah
and I love Jennifer this season a lot that's great
uh her and geralt I think are fantastic together
kind of word they're going to kill off Jennifer
let's read the book and find out let's read
the book tonight let's read the book on camera
they should replace Henry Cavill and then kill
off Jennifer and then we'll focus on District
yes I I I'll watch the D extra spin-off he's fun
to watch him and maybe him and geralt are about
to become an unlikely team I like the rashamoning
this episode too because it's not like a full-on
rashaman but you're just like seeing pieces of a
puzzle scattered about from different character
you're locking into like a certain character
for a little bit and then hopping around
so it's not like different takes of the same
events but it's like okay you're shining a
flashlight on each corner of the event and it's
kind of neat say I like the first 20 minutes it'll
kind of like cut to the middle of a conversation
and stuff yeah or was just like happening so
fast uh it was actually I thought I thought the
pacing that was pretty fun yeah yeah I did too
um like I didn't feel like I was missing out on
anything so I think that's why I appreciate it
ultimately the time thing because I'm like you
didn't need to do the time it's it's very much
like a choice it's a gimmick like it doesn't
really it's a device do it it doesn't lead to
this usually you do something like that to lead
to a big reveal yeah you know yeah but it seemed
like it was all orchestrated around like geralt
finally being like oh you know what I had this
conversation with me oh [__] I think somebody
said this little tiny thing and we recapped the
whole time when we were doing it and I completely
forgot to leave out this one conversation he
talked about not peace what's going on there yeah
and the Jewel but they needed to get the jewelry
that's why yeah I don't know yeah yeah like in
the first half of the episode you're like damn
something crazy is happening and then later on
you're sort of like this is probably a wise choice
to make the distribution of this information a lot
more interesting because otherwise it would have
just felt like a pretty straightforward
conclusion yeah this part of the season
yeah that's weird it was strange but uh I I
still thought it was it's still my favorite
one of the season for sure yeah it was really
fun one undoubtedly it's still my favorite one
I'd rather get episodes like this um where
you get some character substance to really
latch onto and which I know is not what
everyone thinks about the previous episodes
the fun of watching everybody finally thrust
into the tension of the same room yeah yeah
I'd really love who plays Jennifer Anya
shalotra no she's great this is amazing
so amazing yeah well in the comfort that
the two of them have together after so
long like really does it still shines
you know oh don't worry Liam Hemsworth
Apple's gonna leave him this is like a glowing
box of his unique Aura he's gonna drink it up and
it'll be fine I drink your actress yes oh maybe
they can recast everybody moving forward oh that'd
be even better yeah get a new Jennifer that'd be
great yeah Anna Kendrick Yeah Anna Kendrick and
Liam Hemsworth finally Pizza I think they have
done a movie together yeah um I'm not sure about
who cares maybe alrighty guys well are you excited
for Anna Kendrick to take over for the role of
Jennifer leave your thoughts down below what are
your nitpicks that's what we want to know pick
a knit subscribe leave a like hey let's change
your clothes one last time as we do this patreon
David Gandy if there's anyone I would
like to take to a conclave with me
it would be you man I just I hate social events
honestly in more ways than one if you ever see
me at one guys I'm like talking to the same like
four people all the time I don't really talk to
like a whole bunch of people sometimes on a good
day you know like ah all right maybe I'll talk
with a little more people but more often than
not I'm in the mood to get out of there early
um so and so David I want someone to keep me
company the entire time that I could talk with
and hang out with and that way like uh then I
could like you know gossip about the people who
I don't really want to talk to talk to for like
10 seconds and I'm like yeah and Dan I feel like
you're the perfect guy because you're more of a
listener than you are a talker so you'd allow me
the opportunity to feel like comfortable and then
like I'm having a good time socializing tonight
because I just be talking your ear off and you'd
just be listening engaged with that you know that
like cold stare that you gather I'm like I don't
really know if David really likes what I'm saying
right now but I think he does so that's better
David you'd be the perfect one to go to a conclave
with to judge all the other people around us while
we try to make everything better in the world so
that's your magic thank you for being you David
I love you with my whole heart we'll talk soon